the proposal was probably shocking mal
because you were george clooney the guy
who told barbara walters i'm
never going to get married well we never
talked about marriage so
you know we've gone on a safari of all
things which you know i'd never done
before and
i'd never been to any country in the
continent of africa that wasn't
tragic you know and and to go there and
it was this beautiful thing and she
loves giraffes and
these giraffes standing next to her i
was standing behind behind her and she
kind of looked back and she was smiling
and i looked at my buddy benny who was
with us and i just said i'm gonna ask
her to marry me
just like that what and so
we got back and she was she had to go to
london and i prepped it all man and i
got a ring
and i've got it all set up and i'm ready
you know i've got
my aunt rosemary soundtrack and i've got
it
all timed out so i'm going to ask her on
this one song we've never talked about
marriage
you know so i don't know what's going to
happen she might go
ah no and uh
and i hidden the ring took it out of the
box i hid it in a little drawer behind
her and we're in this
tiny room there's a song rosemary saying
called why shouldn't i it's a beautiful
song why should
i take a chance when romance passes by
why shouldn't i know of love it's a
beautiful song
so that's what i'm going to ask her on
i'm really doing it up you know
i've made dinner she lands from london
she comes in
you know she sits down she's exhausted
and you know i've got candlelit and the
food made and
you know everything ready and you know
why shouldn't i come in on the
soundtrack here it comes man i'm gonna
do it
and song hits and i said
you know i think there's a i'd blown out
the candle and i said i think there's a
lighter in that little drawer back there
she kind of leans back and she opens the
drawer and there's a ring in it
and she looks in and she goes now but
there's a ring
like somebody else had left a ring there
you know 10 years ago or something and
i'm like
making every face in the world you know
and i'm on my knee at this point
and uh and then she takes that and she's
holding it and she goes
oh my god and she kept saying oh my god
and i'm on my knee
and now i know exactly how long it took
for her to say yes
because i know what song was playing
when she said yes
and it was 20 minutes i'm on my knee
yeah why is that why do you think was
she she was in shock
and yeah i i'm panicking i'm you sweat
down the back
and i and i'm thinking you know and
finally i said to her look
i just need a yes or no because you know
i'm 50
something and my hip could go out and
right you know and
which we later told that story to her
parents and her father called
this it's very exciting but there's
something wrong with his hip
you